we do have rexing field with us the
founder of the Saint Louis first of all
Rex welcome to the show thank you how do
you feel about this year's U.S
Championship well you know I I knew we
were going to have a chess tournament I
didn't know we were going to have a
circus yes yes this is just amazing
especially yesterday uh did you watch
what happened yeah it's just crazy what
is your take on that
well we have to hear the dialogue you
know what was really going on yeah
people were making inferences about what
was said and it turns out to be wrong
right Sam wasn't challenging him to a
fight he was just trying to get the
peace yeah so uh but the whole thing is
bizarre touching an opponent's piece
taking it off the board that's never
happened never history of Chess they
don't even have a rule on that that's
how rare it is we don't need a rule on
this that'll never happen you know so
yeah they're showing it again this is
gonna that's gonna make the replays for
a long time it will yes so he picks it
up and yeah just an incredible scene
yesterday at the club Rex how about the
chess what players impressed you the
most in this tournament so far well I
have to confess I'm impressed by Irina
by Fabiano both sitting on top of of the
pack and the pack is a group of very
good chess players on both sides so it's
no easy feat to do what they've done and
we'll just see if they can complete what
they're doing I was a little surprised
by fabi's early draw I heard his
interview and I just have to take him in
his word that a draw was good for him
and so I guess he thought that was okay
even though it could have consequences
and we don't want to speculate but we do
think that it's also a big day for a
Levon that is actually what Fabiano was
saying what's his big day perhaps uh a
baby oh so that's what everybody know
it's not being born today it might be
today yes oh my goodness
we don't want to speculate but we assume
that that's what Fabiano meant with what
he said yeah that's that's useful
information for the next time I'm
playing somebody who's about to have a
baby
absolutely Rex uh the club is expanding
in the next year talk to us know that a
little bit yeah how is that going it's
going from 6 000 to 30 000 square feet
and how's it going it's going
expensively
well luckily we have you it'll be nice
when it's completed I mean the plans are
great it's going to be a marvelous place
for playing and we don't have to worry
about expansion after that and we'll
have a facility where we can put on our
own big tournaments you know now we're
limited to 100 or 100 plus but I think
then we'll be able to go over 200 people
on a big tournament we do have
Scholastic tournaments like that those
are very important in our venue of
things and absolutely crucial to our
mission here at the same Luis chess club
also the US trust Federation moved to St
Louis recently how important is that to
the growth of the Syrian chess here well
I was happy to see it and I don't know
how much it will stimulate growth but I
think that people will notice that
certainly those tens of thousands of
members who have their membership with
the USCF and they have to pay their
annual fee they'll notice that they're
sending it now to St Louis and not to
somewhere in Tennessee
and so as I say you know today the USCF
tomorrow free day absolutely absolutely
guys any questions yeah well first of
all Rex uh good to see you very nice to
see you on show
want to see you more actively on the
show but I got a lot of questions about
the sink fill cup and Magnus Carlson's
walking out and those questions are
related to you
how were you impacted by Magnus workout
walking out and did this offend you or
make you think why am I sponsoring chess
or
give us something I never I never asked
myself the last question I never doubted
why I'm doing this I know why I'm doing
it I'm crazy okay we got that we got
that part yeah but I thought about it
and I think
what I said is the more distant you get
from this event the more it looks bad
for Magnus I think
uh what happened was
well it's not clear that anything did
happen other than Magnus withdrawing
from the tournament and I don't see that
as a solution to anything and I don't I
haven't spoken to him I didn't speak to
him that day or anytime thereafter but I
it wouldn't surprise me if he's
questioning himself about why he did
what he did okay but as far as your
commitment to chess that was no way
um disturbed by what took place
as far as your commitment just Yasser is
asking that was not a disturbance no no
not that wouldn't change it really I
mean you're used to weird things going
on
I mean look look at the commentators we
bring in the last month has been just
simply crazy it really has been I hope
you guys have been getting some rest
we've been having a lot of fun
for the wicked over here
you have a question for Rex yeah we have
13 Rounds of these championships do you
prefer this format to have as many
rounds as possible I mean are you
enjoying this format this year it's I
think this is like um usually we have 12
players like 12 players playing catch-up
because of the covet uh Christian do you
feel any difference a bit longer but I
have to say I've always observed in
myself that I enjoy these tournaments as
they go on as they get closer to the end
and that's when the tension is building
and there's going to be at some point
some resolution of it a resolution you
like or maybe one you don't like
but definitely in this one it seems like
you uh picked the right horses oh my
goodness both of them you know in the
women's and the reg and the open uh
coming down to the Final Round Here both
to face playoffs Rex thank you very much
for uh what you're doing for chess and
for chess here in St Louis as well yeah
and thanks to the three of you as I say
oh it pains me to say this yesterday but
I gotta say it you are the three
greatest commentators in the world thank
you thank you we love you too Rex uh
very very very nice indeed